The older I get,
I'm just a plus,
man.
I need a man up.
I used to be so aggressive.
Big Dude,
you're strong.
That's why nobody messes with me.
Oh,
so they leave you alone and that's I because of it.
Yeah,
I know what it's like.
It's like,
um,
like you,
you like fight and all that stuff.
Like I can't even,
like if somebody punched me in the face today,
I don't know how I would react.
Like,
I don't know.
I used to be a bouncer at clubs.
I played college football.
I was a tough dude.
Now everyone apart,
dude,
can I get you to the gym?
No,
no,
no.
I'm in shape.
But I mean like a fight gym.
No.
Why?
No?
I had a little bit.
No,
not to fight people.
Why do you so you don't worry about it?
I never worry about it.
Okay,
well then don't worry about it cause I'm at home at eight 30 [inaudible]
sleeping by nine to stand up.
I know.
I saw you at the Improv the other night.
I have nobody's go jump on stage.
I'm talking about family.
Oh man,
you never know people crazy.
Does anyone want to dude jumped up on the WWF and uh,
attacked.
Uh,
who did he attacked?
He attacked Bret Harte speech.
That's crazy.
It's gotta be like,
how old is he now?
He's a stroke survivor.
So fucked up and they got tackled him.
Jesus.
But Joe,
seriously,
you think anybody's going to jump on stage when you're on some dude and could
easily,
you would fucking kill him.
No,
this,
there's a lot of people they can kill me.
You don't get confused now I know a lot of have been here all the time.
I get that.
But like I,
I,
I just don't see me doing stand up talking about family and love and a dude
because I hate family and love.
I'm gonna jump up.
It's that.
It's not rational.
Nothing.
Right?
A rational person wouldn't do that,
but you're not worried about rational people anyway.
Okay.
So,
so say I started to go to a fight gym.
Like where would I start at?
Like what I do,
I would say you should try Jiu Jitsu cause it's fun.
It's really good exercise and you'll learn some stuff.
You learn how to do it.
It's a technique based art where it's like,
say if,
um,
if you like,
there's,
there's guys that I will,
uh,
do Jiu Jitsu sparring.
We call rolling.
Okay.
There's guys that I will roll with that are weaker than me,
smaller than me and tap me every time I wrote with them and I'm a black belt.
Okay.
That's reality.
Like if there's,
there's guys out there that are 150 pounds that I can roll with that I know will
tap me virtually every time we roll because their technique is sharper.
They train more often than I am.
They're more focused,
they're more in the groove.
But I also heard you say like one of your podcasts,
you've got to watch out who you train with because they might just try to hurt
you.
That's trying need,
I need,
you got to go to a good school with good ethics because a good school with good
ethics,
they get rid of those guys.
Did you know,
do you know one in studio city?
I'm sure I'll get,
yeah,
no,
I'll do it.
I want to learn,
there's a good spot,
just a little further than that and Tarzana.
Okay.
Machado's where I got my black belt.
So John Jacques Machado.
I train there sometimes and um,
he used to have a place in Malibu but closed down because of the fires.
Um,
but they um,
they have an outstanding CIM.
It's like one of the best in the country and it's in that area as far as
teaching top notch like,
but there's a lot of really good Jujitsu schools now.
It's not like I'm like when I started in [inaudible] 96,
it was hard to find a good gym.
There was only like five of them in all of California.
Right.
Cause it was just starting out.
I was like 93 is when Jujitsu sort of emerged in the public consciousness
because of the UFC.
And then the,
the gym started like popping up,
popping up.
But I was really lucky.
There was like Hixon Gracie's,
which is where I took my first class and then Carlson Gracie's,
I thought they were like the same.
And the other one was closer,
so I just switched to Carlson's.
I didn't know shit.
You know,
it was white belt but,
and then there was a Machado's and then like a couple other places.
How long does it take you to get to a black belt?
Like for you?
Some guy took me a long time.
I was a brown belt for eight years,
but it was just because I wasn't training as much as I should have.
Like they,
you don't,
they don't give them away.
Like you have to be a real black belt.
But I just mean who decides what is somebody just watched instructors and you
do?
No.
Okay.
Well everyone knows.
It's like,
like you know when a guy is fucking killing,
like,
like he,
let's take like Theo Vaughan for example,
like Theo,
I love him.
He hit a groove sometime ago,
whether it's two years ago or whatever it was.
And I remember being in the back of the store and I was like,
dude,
this motherfucker's on fire.
Yeah.
He started hitting that groove.
That where,
where you go and sit down,
you want to watch is set,
you know.
And I think when that happens in Jujitsu,
it's the same kind of thing.
Guys started talking to my like,
dude,
Mike has been tapping everybody,
he's just his,
his Jujitsu so sharp and you're like,
man,
I'm gonna Watch them roll.
And then you watch them.
Only like two that pass at guard pass and it got to start asking like how often
are you training?
I'm going five days a week now.
Really Yad,
I'm taking two privates block.
And then you know,
like this guy is on the quest and you'll see a guy go from white belt to black
belt in three years,
but they have to be super exceptional,
like really unusual athletes.
Unusual mindset,
unusual discipline.
It can happen most of the time,
like a garden variety estimate is like 10 years is realistic.
White belt to black belt for a regular person.
If you really train hard and you really dedicate yourself,
but freaks can get there quicker.
Like Bj Penn,
he won the Moon Dealz which is the world championships.
After three years of training,
three years of training.
He was a black belt one.
The world child should be doing that to PJ's a special guy though.
I used also got legs that are like arms.
He,
he has leg dexterity like no one on the planet.
I got the chicken legs.
It's actually good.
Is it really?
Yeah.
You could cinch up triangles on people with chicken legs.
Yeah,
for real and are sitting up.
People everywhere though.
Just think about it in terms of leverage guys with longer limbs,
like a hydra Gracie's a perfect example.
He's a really tall long guy.
So on the best Jujitsu players ever,
they can do things with those limbs that a shorter person can't do in terms of
like leverage from joints and stuff like this.
Like there's advantages to every frame.
Like there's a guy like who some are Paul Horez,
a famous like tank of a guy.
He's like five,
seven,
200 plus pounds and just rips guy's legs apart.
And he uses this like short style to dive in on people's legs and get them in
heal hooks and bars and rip their legs parties terrifying and that that style
heavily favors being built like a little tank.
Whereas like that long like you are,
you're a tall long guy,
you would have like good Darce choke,
good rear nakeds good or good arm bars,
good triangles.
You would have lengthened leverage with that length.
Especially with triangles cause long legged guys they can like sometimes a guy
like me with short legs like I'll,
I'll get my legs crossed and I have to adjust a lot to be able to cinch up by
triangle.
Whereas you might be able to just close it up right there.
So you'll have like more opportunities for triangles because the length of your
limbs.
And have you,
would you have ever been at a point in your,
in your career when you were doing to just where you,
how would you have been in the UFC?
Like it's your prime like I have no idea.
I'd have no idea.
I would have had to have gotten way better.
Like when I was fighting,
I was just kickboxing.
Yeah,
kickboxing.
And first of all,
first it was taekwondo and then went to kickboxing.
And by the time the UFC came around,
like on the ground,
I was useless.
Okay.
There's a straight white belt.
I would get ripped apart every day.
I would go to the gym and if I,
if I tapped anybody,
like if it was like a week went by and I tapped one guy be like,
Woo,
I fucking tapped the guy buddy.
There wasn't that many people doing it,
you know?
So I was going with like,
there was a couple of white belts may be,
and then there was like blue belts and purple belts and Brown belts and those
guys would always tap me.
Got It.
So that's just how it went for a long time.
When you are,
you know,
unless you're some kind of freak like some big ass football player or some like
super athlete,
you're probably not going to be behold,
hold these guys off.
They're gonna,
they're gonna choke you.
Now.
Was it true?
You're gonna a fight.
Wesley snipes.
That was way later though,
way later.
That was a brown belt by then and I'd been doing a long for you beaten them.
I don't know cause we never did ever deserve real martial artist,
real martial arts.
But he doesn't know Jujitsu.
The thing that must have been exciting though for super excited cause I was
thinking like I knew that he was a real legitimate martial artists.
Like he throws kicks and punches and it looks really good.
Like he really does know his shit.
But I also know he never fought.
And there's a big difference between throwing kicks and I and I haven't fought
in a long time,
but I probably fought a hundred times.
Yeah.
So I,
I,
I've been,
I've felt that nerves,
I know what that's like.
It'll be crazy as fuck to do it again.
That's what I was thinking.
I'm like,
it'll probably scare the shit out of me,
but I think I know what to do.
Like,
I think I know how to like get in there and start fainting and start giving some
movement and see how he reacts.
And then the worst case scenarios,
like I'm like in a scramble,
I'm going to strangle this guy.
Like if this,
if this comes to a scramble because the average person really doesn't know how
helpless are until a Jujitsu black belt grabs a hold of you and then you just
go,
oh shit.
Like I'm helpless because in a fight you really think like you might be able to
punch a guy.
Like maybe if he's friendly and he's swinging at me and I'm swinging at him,
maybe I hit him first.
You really think that,
but there's no swinging.
If it's a Jujitsu fight,
if,
if you guys get into some sort of a tussle and that guy grabs you and trips you
in,
boom,
and he's on the ground with his hand on your Jack and a knee on your chest,
you're a dead man.
You're a dead man because there's no lucky shots.
Yeah,
a Jujitsu black belt is just going to close the distance like that evil fucking
crab.
And he's just going to use your fucking neck and there's no way you're going to
avoid it and there's no way you're going to survive it.
You're just not going to.
That's why you don't fight people like five people and I'm just,
you can't fight random people on the streets like when you're young.
That was the thing that you could go to bars.
Yeah.
Like I,
I had some friends that like to throw down when I was younger and I,
I wouldn't do that.
I was watching but good for you.
Now it's kind of like you've got to watch everybody because you don't know what
kind of training they're doing.
Like everybody is so educated on and it's so big right now.
Well some guy fought off a guy in the subway that was attacking with a knife
with some moves that he learned watching the UFC never even trained before he
just knew what to do.
Yeah.
He like knew what to do because he'd seen guys like get the mountain and drop
ground and pound.
He like knew what to do based on watching it.
Yeah.
I think is good.
Like when you mentioned,
I think it's good just to learn so you would feel better about yourself in case
danger comes.
Yeah,
man.
You want to be the person that gets to make the decision.
Here's the thing,
right?
If you don't know how to fight and there's some drunk asshole who doesn't know
how to fight either,
but he might come over and punch you in the face and sucker punch you and he
could hurt you or knock you out in front of your woman.
You want to be the one who gets to decide.
If I'm in a situation in some guy and he's like reasonably close to my size and
he's being an asshole and he's drunk and he gets aggressive with me,
I can decide what to do with him.
Like I can,
it gets,
I don't want to hurt anybody,
but I'm not gonna let you hurt me and you get to decide like you don't want.
Like you've,
we've all seen these seven 11 fucking parking lot fights on youtube or some
asshole and both of them don't know how to fight,
but one guy might fuck that guy up.
He might kick them in the face while he's down.
He don't want to be that guy,
but you don't want to be in that situation.
Definitely walk away whenever you can.
Always.